>>> Well, this is what I was
excited for.
Our next guest's dream is to
become an astrophysicist.
Taking the steps towards that
dream.
He finished high school in under
three years with a 4.0 GPA and
finished a nester of college.
Here is the I can kicker.
He is 9.
That is him.
In addition being one of the
youngest high school graduates in
the company, he is a member of
mensa.
His parents join us now.
My goodness.
>> Good morning!
>> Hey, David.
How is college?
>> Good.
>> What was it like graduating
from high school at 9?
>> Well, everybody started
talking about how this is an
incredible accomplishment, and I
was thinking how all I did was
graduate.
And then my mom saying, yes, you
graduated at the age of 9, and
then I say, yeah, I graduated.
What's the big deal?
You graduated at the age of 9.
So what is the big deal?
>> So what is the big deal?
Do you know what the big deal
is?
This is normal to you?
>> It just comes.
You just, for me, you just do
it.
>> So, mom and dad, what did you
do?
Every parent watching is like,
wait a minute, what did they do
and what am I doing wrong?
Did you do anything special, you
think, or different that puts
David ahead of the pack?
>> I think you just have to
listen to your child and get
outside of the box.
He was the one leading the
charge.
He is the one that was
motivated.
I just had to break out of the
box and think outside of the
normal schooling, think outside
of what people know and what I
know growing up and just give
him a chance to be and do what
he is dreaming to be and do.
>> What could you mean by that?
>> Sorry.
Go ahead, dad.
>> Go ahead.
>> In addition to that, there
are so many factors that we saw
very early when David was
growing up.
He is the type that is very
curious about everything.
And everywhere we went, he
always asked, what is this?
What is that?
And then if you explain and you
use big words, he will want you
to break it down and it he will
me what does that mean.
And when he comes with me to my
clinic, I have an outpatient
psychiatric clinic.
When he comes to me, I mean, to
the clinic, he always asks
questions.
Why do you do this as opposed to
doing that?
And what does this mean?
Instead of, you know.
And you have to explain without
explaining, if you know what I
mean, because you still have to
pay attention to the
requirements of the law.
We keep patients' information
highly confidential because of
the hippa law.
And I still have to break it
down for him.
I never said to him, shut up!
Or go and do something else.
No.
I would take the time to break
this down.
>> Dad, I am going to make this
point with poppy.
When I was a kid, my mom would
pull me back, I'd go talk to
my
dad would say don't make him
afraid of people.
Let him be curious.
You do the same thing.
Don't tell them no.
>> We can't do that now, but
what else can we do.
David, what do you want to be
when you grow up, David?
>> Well, there are a few things
that I want to be.
An astrophysicist, an engineer,
a nuclear chemist, a software
developer, to rocket engineer.
What's the last one?
Website designer.
>> Nothing like -- a ballplayer
would be great, too.
He has all kinds of skills.
Sure he could do it.
David and mom and dad, we have a
surprise for you, okay?
Ready?
>> Okay.
>> One of the world's most
famous scientists wants to say
hi to you.
Astrophysicist Neil Degrasse
Tyson is here with us.
Hi, Neil, good morning!
>> Are you serious?
>> Hey, everybody.
Hey!
Hey, David.
>> Good morning!
>> How are you?
>> Yeah.
Hey, David, I was 9 when I
decided I wanted to be an
astrophysicist, except I was
still in fourth grade, okay?
[ Laughter ]
In case you didn't know this, it
is unusual to be entering
college at that grade.
But the greatest value to
knowing this early, what you
might want to do, looks like you
are giving yourself a few
options there, and that's great.
The greatest value is you can
align decisions related to your
life to feed that interest and
curiosity.
So that by the time you become a
professional in that world, your
whole life has been invested on
that path and then you will
become better at that than
anything else you could imagine.
So I am especially intrigued you
know what you want to be when
you are grown up.
So you are kind of already grown
up, so I don't know what that
means.
>> David, is there anything you
want to is say to the great Neil
Degrasse Tyson before he with
got to go?
>> Well, we are really blessed
to have you talk to David.
I mean, he has read so much
about you and heard so much
about you and every time he sees
you on the TV and doing
something somewhere, he is
always impressed.
>> Dad, let him talk about it.
>> To talk to you --
>> Let him talk about it, dad.
>> Go ahead.
>> How to you feel?
>> Yes.
>> Go ahead.
>> How do you feel?
>> So, I have created -- so I
was in my Earth and science high
school class.
I created a theory to refute
"The big bang theory."
>> Wow!
>> We love new ideas.
>> So the main -- thanks.
>> Keep going.
>> So the main part of the
theory is that matter cannot be
created or destroyed.
According to the big
bang theory, I guess you will
call it bal cosmic eck,
something like that, it was
infinitely dense.
In order for it to be infinitely
dense, it has to be constantly
creating matter.
>> Oh, my gosh.
>> But in order for it to
constantly be creating matter,
it would have to violate the
laws of physics.
Since we are technically talking
about the universe, not all the
space outside of the universe,
then the laws of physics should
still apply.
>> Wait.
Neil, hang on one second.
We have to go, sorry, David, we
are just out of time.
I don't mean to be
disrespectleful from a
9-year-old who graduated
college.
Neil, is he schooling you right
now?
We got to run.
>>ING so we love new ideas.
That challenge our previous
ideas.
In the end, David, come up with
a way to test your idea.
Then we can then hand it over to
people with telescopes and space
probes and this sort of thing
and we can see if your new
hypothesis about the universe is
correct, that that's how we do
that.
That's how we roll on the
frontier.
>> We roll -- we have time.
We have to deal with time issues
here and get to breaks and pay
the bills.
We are so happy to have all of
you on.
David, best of luck to you.
Mom and dad, as well.
Neil, very kind of you.
>> My day has been made.
>> By the way.
>> Go ahead.
>> My podcast coming to the
keswick theater in Pennsylvania
outside of philly at the end of
March.
I would be delighted to offer
your family some tickets for
that.
>> That would be great!
>> That would be amazing.
Thank you very much.
>> We'd love to meet you all in
person.
David, keep us abreast of what
you are doing.
Good luck.